mit einem starken infrarotlaser kontakt
zu außerirdischen lebensform aufnehmen
diese idee kommt vom renommierten
massachusetts institute of technology
mit in cambridge demnach könnten wir mit
unseren technischen möglichkeiten schon
in wenigen jahren solch einen laser
bauen dessen leuchtsignal man noch in
einer entfernung von 28.000 lichtjahren
entdecken könnte das forschungsteam
schreibt dass sich damit sogar eine
botschaft in einer art morsecode setzen
ließ wie stark müsste solch ein leser
sein und wie genau könnte die
kommunikation mit außerirdischem leben
ablaufen und ist es chance oder gefahr
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt's
täglich faszinieren sie science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
das weltall weiteres leben existiert
davon sind viele forschungsteams
felsenfest überzeugt doch wie können wir
es auch spüren
wie können wir mit möglichen
außerirdischen kontakt aufnehmen und
könnten sie uns vielleicht sogar den weg
zu lebensfreundlichen planeten ebenen
ein team von emmi hat jetzt einen neuen
vorschlag gemacht wie wir menschen
außerirdische auf uns aufmerksam machen
könnten und zwar mit hilfe eines
künstlichen leuchtsignal konkret könnte
dies mit einem infrarotlaser möglich
sein ein sehr starker leser mit einer
leistung von 2 megawatt wäre dafür
notwendig und zudem auch einen
mindestens 30 bis 45 meter großes
teleskop
dies würde dafür sorgen dass der
infrarot laser scharf gebündelt ins alte
leuchten könnte beides wäre nach ansicht
des forschungsteams technologisch
gesehen schon jetzt beziehungsweise in
sehr naher zukunft möglich dazu einer
der studienautoren james clark es wäre
ein herausforderndes projekt aber kein
unmöglich
im besten fall könnte das signal dann
noch in einer entfernung von bis zu
20.000 lichtjahren nachzuweisen sein
das sind ganze 80 der strecke bis zum
zentrum der milchstraße
die größte herausforderung sei es bei
dem projekt die sonne zu überstrahlen
und dies ist natürlich nur mit einem
unheimlich starken leser umzusetzen den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern schrieb deswegen ein
leser vor der etwa eine milliarde mal
stärker ist als gewöhnliche laserpointer
wow dem plan zufolge müsste dieser am
besten auf einem berg gebaut werden denn
somit könnte verhindert werden dass das
signal auf seinem weg in der atmosphäre
verzerrt wird doch klar ist auch objekte
im erd- orbit wie satelliten wären durch
solch einen starken laserstrahl gefährt
das forschungsteam hatte deswegen auch
schon die idee die rückseite des mondes
als standort für dieses projekt
auszuwählen
und es geht noch weiter denn mit dem
laser könnten wir menschen ja nicht nur
durch das starke leuchtsignal auf uns
aufmerksam machen sondern sogar
kommunizieren dem team zufolge wären
botschaften aus einigen dutzend zeichen
möglich die pro sekunde lichtjahre weit
ins all getragen werden könnten dazu
klagt wenn wir eine verbindung mit
nachbarn einrichten könnten könnten wir
einen botschaften morgen die in einigen
jahren dort ankommen könnte klar ist
aber auch je weiter die anderen bisher
noch unbekannte zivilisation entfernt
ist desto langjähriger würde die
kommunikation natürlich werden ganze
acht jahre beispielsweise müssten wir
uns auf der erde gedulden bis eine
antwort eintreffen würde die direkt vom
nächsten nachbarn stern der sonne namens
proxima centauri an uns gerichtet würde
proxima centauri ist vier lichtjahre
entfernt unglaubliche lange 1000 jahre
würde es dagegen dauern bis eine antwort
einer außerirdischen zivilisation
erreichen würde die in einer entfernung
von 500 lichtjahren existiert bereits
laufende beziehungsweise umgesetzte
projekte zeigen dass die idee technisch
gesehen tatsächlich gar nicht so
unrealistisch ist beispielsweise hat in
die amerikanische luftwaffe schon einmal
einen megawatt leser an den start
gebracht der sollte ursprünglich dazu
dienen den luftraum zu schützen und
raketen vom himmel zu schießen aber
keine sorge es mittlerweile stillgelegt
und auch der bau eines sehr großen
teleskops liegt durchaus im
waren das zeigt das beispiel der
europäischen südsternwarte eso die in
chile derzeit ein teleskop ort der
geplante durchmesser beträgt 39 m dazu
klar
grundsätzlich war das eine
machbarkeitsstudie ob es eine gute idee
ist oder nicht ist diskussionsstoff und
künftige arbeiten
stephen hawking jedenfalls hatte dazu
eine ganz klare meinung er riet von
einer kontaktaufnahme mit aliens ab
seiner meinung nach könnte dies dazu
führen dass sie überhaupt auf uns
aufmerksam werden und uns dann zerstören
außerirdische mega zivilisationen finden
so könnte es gehen drauf klickt auf
dieses video anschauen und neugier zone
abonnieren bis dann bleibt da